the NBA playoffs are about to start and
for most of this year the Eastern
Conference has had teams with losing
records in the playoff race but you
shouldn't be complaining that much to
put it in perspective in 1985 1986 the
Chicago Bulls had a team with only 30
wins make the playoffs and this wasn't
even the worst Chicago Bulls team in
67-68
a team with 29 wins made the playoff
high this is pressure Locker and in this
video I'm going to explain that under
the NBA rules it's possible for team
with only eight wins to make the
playoffs to begin let's go over the NBA
structure there are two conferences
there's a Western Conference and an
Eastern Conference inside of each
conference there are three divisions and
each division has five teams each and
from each division one team is
guaranteed a playoff spot the NBA has 82
games in a year 30 of the games are
scheduled against non-conference
opponents that's two games versus 15
teams each there are also 36 games that
are scheduled within the conference
you'll play some teams four times and
other teams three times for a total of
36 games finally there are 16 games that
are scheduled within the division so
each team plays its four division rivals
four times each what's the least number
of wins all the teams in a division
could have well clearly they could lose
all of their 30 non-conference games
they could also all five of these teams
could lose all of their games against
teams within the same conference but not
in the same division
the only thing where they're going to be
forced to win is that when they play
division teams the best team in the
division will at least
have a twins and the reason for this is
that every loss for one team is a win
for another so if two teams without wins
face each other one of them will be
forced to get a win mathematically the
best team always has to have eight or
more wins so in the worst case scenario
all teams all five teams within division
could have an eight and 74 record and
one of those teams is guaranteed a
playoff spot to be at least the fourth
seed so this is absolutely crazy the
rule should probably be changed so you
don't have such horrible teams make the
playoffs and it also goes to show you if
a team only has 30 wins they really
didn't win more than they were
guaranteed to win against their
divisional rivals that's only about 22
more wins than the guaranteed minimum
just to make the playoffs I hope you
like this video please subscribe to my
channel you can get my books there's a
link in the description of the video you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook and Google+ you can catch me at
Prestwick or on Twitter Instagram Tumblr
and Pinterest and you can support me on
patreon